the man the myth the legend of espn he
has
turned himself into a cottage industry
the host and reporter
uh from espn on mma podcaster
and bill's slash knicks fan ariel
helwani here on the rich eisen show how
are you ariel
i'm doing great rich how are you i'm
very envious of you you got to talk to
three of my uh my favorite players
yesterday unfortunately it didn't turn
out well for us
on sunday night but i'm very proud of my
buffalo bills and we will be back
you heard it here first i appreciate
that ariel yeah chris brockman he uh he
direct messaged me during uh game day
morning aft as i was as i was
interviewing jim kelly
right in the middle and thomas and andre
reid so
you know you're you're uh you're you're
die-hard so um
look man it's just not your time i i
it's kind of it's kind of like um
you know uh uh being caught up in
in a moment uh in time that is uh
bad timing sort of like ewing when
jordan was around you know i mean
because you feel the same way you know
and and it's the crazy thing is that uh
brady
is now out of the division and out of
the conference and he may be that for
mahomes still it's kind of crazy when
you think about it it is
yeah and he's 24 and i feel like we'll
see him again
but uh look you know he he he stumbled
in the afc championship of course
against an older team
a couple years ago and uh we stumbled
yesterday and i'll say we
because uh you know i've been on this
train with the bills since 1990 when i
saw scott norwood
go wide right against the giants but i
will say just very quickly i know you
didn't have me on to talk about no it's
all good
i will forever i will forever forever be
in debt
to coach mcdermott josh allen stefan
diggs that entire team
because it's tough times here rich and
as you know sports is the ultimate
escape
and you know i miss my family back home
in canada and to have this team do what
they did this year and as a father now
for the first time
getting to watch games with my sons who
are wearing a digs and allen jersey
and even my six-year-old son sat with me
until the end yesterday and i
he saw how sad i was and that's how i
fell in love with this team when my
heart was broken by
them and it's just an amazing thing so i
will forever be thankful to those guys
for giving us what they gave us
this you know fall and winter and i
can't wait to see where they go from
here
no we're not sad today we're happy
because it happened
and i think the future is very bright
for the buffalo bills yeah the bills are
i've got uh i've got josh allen and
diggs and
and mcdermott and so many pieces are in
place now you know
which team to target to actually try and
put your team together to
to help surpass i just love the fact too
as we're you know talking to bill's
mafia with ariel helwani right here
i love the fact that diggs was standing
out there the only bill out there
standing watching
these chiefs celebrate with the the the
trophy named after their founder
just i i just love everything about
stefan diggs
i love that man made me cry seeing that
and then to see mcdermott
come out and console him and i saw
another clip today of of josh
going up to every single player it was
like a three-minute clip
and hugging them and you see the love
that they have for him as well and the
respect
this this young man has come a long way
over the past three years even dating
back to
last year's playoff where he looked
shell-shocked in houston um
i'm just so proud of these guys and i'm
proud to be a bills fan when i was a kid
i was tormented for being a bill's fence
because i have two older brothers who
are cowboys fans
and we were you know we were the boy i
love losing super bowl team right
everyone used to make fun of us
those days are over we're no longer a
laughing stock the bills will be back i
have no doubt about it ariel helwani
here on the rich eisen show
let's get into the bread and butter
let's go back into our lane if you if uh
in that respect
um what happened with conor mcgregor
over the weekend
what happened conor mcgregor fought a
really really good fighter
uh there is no shame in losing to dustin
poirier you can make
the claim that he's the second best
lightweight in the world and
it's important to note lightweight
because that's the best division in mma
right now certainly in the ufc the most
stacked by far you know it really
bothered me
when this fight was first announced and
i get it you know conor brings out
casual fans who don't follow this sport
as closely as the hardcores and
certainly not myself and
i i saw a lot of people saying like why
is he fighting a guy who he beat
in less than two minutes six and a half
years ago what's the point in this you
hardly see fights like this in boxing
and i wanted people to know justin
poirier was a much different fighter
today on saturday than the guy who conor
fought six and a half years ago he's
improved
incredibly and and not just from a
physical standpoint but from a mental
standpoint as well
the guy who fought conor six and a half
years ago was you know
a bit immature and let conor get in his
head under his skin
and we saw on saturday that he's a
tremendous fighter and so
the better man juan uh he had an amazing
game plan
everyone said he had to take him down
early he did clinch with him he did
and then he attacked that lead leg those
calf kicks are just
insanely dangerous and you saw what
happened connor could hardly stand up
so he had the great game plan conor you
know mentioned that he was rusty didn't
offer any excuses
and so maybe they'll do it again but you
know make no mistake about it this
wasn't buster douglas
this was conor losing to a fighter who
is just as good as he is
is conor as good as he was how about
that for a question losing two out of
his last three
how about that one ariel it's a fair
question
i mean it's it's worth noting that going
into this fight
he fought for a collective 40 seconds
dating back to october of 2018.
i do believe that cage rush ring rust is
a real thing
you're just you know and meanwhile
poirier is fighting two three times a
year
and he's usually fighting you know 10 15
25 minute fights like this guy
gets into brawls um so i'm not ready
at 32 years old to write off conor
mcgregor uh you'll recall back in 2016
he lost to nate
diaz he dusted himself off and then he
came back and beat him and then
followed that performance up with his
best performance ever against eddie
alvarez at madison square garden so
i i think he'll be back in fact i just
got off the
zoom if he was going to say phone but
zoom with his head coach john kavanagh
and he told me that they want dustin
trilogy fight in may this time for the
vacant title so he has already decided
what he wants next now we'll see if the
ufc obliges
but this man wants to get right back on
the horse and it's very reminiscent to
2016.
the day after he lost to diaz he said i
want him again let's make it happen so
we'll see if he can write this wrong
okay but we've never seen that trilogy
right so what's next for both of these
fighters ariel
so so i think i think conor is going to
be very
uh persuasive about doing it again right
away
third fight dustin versus connor three
um
i would be shocked if the ufc doesn't
listen there's a lot of money to be made
there i think you could sell it very
easily
uh you got two guys who are one and one
against each other so that's an option
obviously connor versus nate three is an
option as well you can sell that one
really easily
you got the trilogy fight um they're
both coming off losses now so they could
get back on track
nate is out there campaigning for dustin
and they were supposed to fight two
years ago so you can obviously sell that
there's bad blood there's a guy named
charles oliveira who deserves
a crack at the belt he could be an
option what i know for sure is this
the ufc has options and that's a great
spot to be in i do believe that dustin's
next fight should be for the vacant
title khabib nurmagomedov
is the current lightweight champion but
he has made it very clear
he wants to retire i think we should
respect his wishes
he wants to retire because his dad
passed away last year and his mom has
asked him to walk away
respect that let him give up the title
dustin
should fight for the belt next he should
probably be the champion already that
fight on saturday should have been for
the belt but let him fight for the
vacant title
and let's keep this division rolling
along ariel helwani here on the rich
eisen show
uh what's with uh jon jones gaining 30
pounds
what are we growing from all of this
ariel he looks good
uh he he wants to move up to heavyweight
so so he gave up his title he gave up
his light heavyweight belt
there's a new champion there named
yambohovic he's fighting israel
yesterday now your guy
is the odessa he's fighting him on march
6th
and so they just officially uh
finalized a heavyweight title fight
between the champions
that's a rematch of a fight that
happened in 2018 that's going to be an
amazing fight that's march 27th
john will fight the winner of that fight
i would say
august september or so and what a huge
fight that will be jon jones who in my
opinion has never lost he has one loss
on his record but it was a dq and it
it shouldn't have been a dq is a mistake
by the referee moving up to heavyweight
for the first time
essentially undefeated going up against
the champion either stipe
who's the greatest heavyweight champ in
ufc history or francis
who who hits like a freaking you know
like a mack truck i mean the guy is just
insane
that's that's big business for the ufc
so they've got a lot of big fights
pretty much at their doorstep in in 2021
let's see if they can
you know make them all happen israel a
destiny that's how you
uh uh because when he came here he's
like uh out of sonia did he change it or
did i just botch it to in front of his
face he never corrected me
what about that one he's a mensch rich
as you know the guy you know he
he's a good man and uh we have sort of
americanized it
okay okay so israel
um is my guy we're referring to him as
my guy just because he's
i said here you want to do this i heard
you're a big fan well i'm a huge fan
look anybody who comes on my show and
keeps dropping the the the sound bites
that he drops
uh talking about wanting to scrape his
scrape his manhood across the face of
jon jones in the home of the las vegas
raiders i mean he had me at hello
pretty much carol to be honest with you
rich i i feel like you have uh
unlocked a whole new world here don't
you realize when you have fighters on
and when you talk
fighting do you realize that the clips
always do way better than the
traditional sports
these fight fans are starved for
mainstream broadcasters and mainstream
shows such as
yourself and your show to shed a light
on these individuals
and could we be honest for the most part
aren't they all fantastic interviews
like you don't get a lot of cliche right
no you are
by the way plus one i am all in on that
i mean we had
well i mean we had ryan uh garcia the
other day
and um the king dropped that
that he you know once again that he
plans to retire at age 26 to
get all negativity out of the world and
i i kind of
you know question that not that that's
not a very
noble gesture or or concept but you know
age 26
you know how is he going to be
understand that he's done get it all out
of his system he then even said that he
he's never told this to anybody that
he'd like to take on
the world of mma that he would like to
go to ufc
pretty much after all that and that went
everywhere
so i'm i'm all in on that what did you
think of that ariel
so yeah and and by the way i'm happy you
mentioned that because we wrote about it
on uh.com thank you it made headlines
everywhere so again
there's an opportunity really to uh to
shed a light on these guys uh
i don't believe that he is going to
retire 26 you hear this from fighters
all the time
especially ones who are that talented as
he is
and you know he hasn't taken a lot of
damage throughout his career of course
the next few years can change
um and quite frankly there's more money
for him to be made like the boxing model
lends itself to make more money witness
the fact that conor made the most amount
of money in his career when he fought
mayweather that one time
so i think that ryan garcia is a master
promoter he's a very bright young man
he's he's incredible box office he's got
the look he's got the fighting style
he's got he's got he's got the
the nationality he's got people behind
him all that stuff why would you leave
and go to a sport that you don't know
anything about
you don't have the ground skills you
don't have the wrestling you don't have
the jiu jitsu you're doing well
in boxing and you're going to continue
to do well and you're making
a boatload of money so i think you know
he's in he's involved in a bit of a war
with
oscar de la hoya his promoter part of
this i think is him needling him a
little bit
um i would be shocked i'm not trying to
suggest he was disingenuous to you no
but i would be very surprised if this
happened
no look ariel i'm i'm not above being
used uh
in some sort of fight between uh all
world famous boxer and all world famous
boxer turned promoter um
i have no problem being used like that
as long as they spell my name right
you know two eyes and rich and eisen you
know me absolutely yeah
the uh long time uh new york knicks fan
they can throw that one
i got it no ariel
thank you no no i will i will say this
as you know i despise the owner with
every with a fury of a thousand sons
actually i'm i'm probably
i'm probably uh understating the amount
of sons with which i hate this man
um and maybe it's because the fact that
i don't see him smugly sitting there
sipping coffee with two
agent-appropriate ladies on either side
just sitting there and watching the team
uh just be terrible in front of him
but all that said uh they are really fun
to watch
they are fun to watch ariel so go ahead
you can crow
i'll give you this i'll give you the
platform for that go for it and it's
because of one man and one man only the
man who they should have hired
three coaching hires ago the great tom
thibodeau
former nick's assistant under the great
jeff van gundy they should have hired
him
when he left chicago i thought i mean
the hires over the past few years from
fisher to fizdale i mean just
one mess after the next jeff hornacek as
well of course
he has given this team an identity of
course are they missing a lot of parts
yes but he's making them play hard as a
team defense is tremendous
i think they'll be in the mix for the
playing game um
you know do they make the playoffs who
knows but emmanuel quickly
yesterday 31 points i believe off top my
head what a great pick that was and
everyone was making fun of the kentucky
nick
well guess what the kentucky knicks are
doing pretty darn well i believe in new
york and we would like to have you back
this is perfect i don't know i think i
think i torched that bridge like it's
over the river quad to be honest with
you um i think i blew that thing
completely no but i do but it is it is
weird to see julius randle wearing
bernard king's number but he's don
he's he's been dominant i mean it's just
the only word for him
um i just but they're they're a better
roster they're they're better formed
it's not some sort of bizarre mix of
of kids and veterans that don't work or
aren't ready to work together
it's it's a they're a better team man
there's no question about it
they are a better team i'll put up i'll
put it this way
in 1985 when the knicks got the first
pick
in the first ever nba draft lottery i
believe it was televised on cbs
and there was a shot of the great the
late great dave the busher going crazy
as you may recall
and i believe it was pat o'brien on the
broadcast who said and i
quote basketball is back in new york
city my friends and i'm not talking
about that team in brooklyn
i'm talking about the new york
knickerbockers basketball is back in new
york city rich
and we'd love to have you on board i
know i appreciate that
thank you ariel and thanks for the call
here uh a fun weekend uh
of news and obviously great fights from
fight island
ufc 257 i'll give you the floor
i can't keep track with everything
that's worthy of promoting that you're
doing so
go for it before i let you go here you
don't have to promote anything
i would just ask for one favor over the
next few weeks sure can you do me this
one favor
i'm assuming you're going to tampa right
for the super bowl you're obviously
going to be doing a lot of coverage
can you can you find a way to mention
the fact
that the best storyline about this game
isn't
you know bucks at home old versus young
mahomes brady it's the fact that former
montreal expo's draft pick
tom brady is going up against former
montreal expo's reliever
son patrick mahomes senior son the great
patrick mahomes jr so if you can find a
way to reference
in particular closer to kickoff on
sunday a mention of the late great
montreal expos
it would warm my heart because i mean
look at us 16 17 years after our demise
we're still relevant you know tom brady
was was drafted by the expos back in the
day right
uh you're actually teaching me something
new i did not know that
well there you go i have a very quickly
frank robinson 2004 spring training i
went to spring training as a student
melbourne florida
i wrote a fake letter to the expos and i
asked them if i could cover them
um in their final season i was a student
at syracuse university
no one was applying for credentials so
they said sure and i i wrote in my
journal i went back and found it on my
parents house frank robinson the late
great frank robinson in the dugout
eating popcorn
with a young pat mahomes who was there
because his dad was trying out for the
team as a reliever
and all these years later look at this
so a lot of montreal expo's love i j
if you could just throw it in there i'd
be forever inside somewhere warren
cromartie is beaming
ariel thank you for dropping that
knowledge right here
on the show how about that steve rogers
somewhere hold on okay get another good
one right here
um larry parish chris spy
tim wallach my god how could i forget
about tim we're all beaming
for you so i'll i'll try i'll try that
one on for size
thanks for uh thanks for downloading me
with that you take care of yourself
brother
you too at ariel helwani on both twitter
and instagram the host of ariel and the
bad guy on espn plus in the mma show
his podcast ariel helwani here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here